[Music]
so
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii irene s
was born in 1925 in berezani of zajani
galicia now ukraine and was raised in
grujon's poland
she was a survivor of the bialystok
ghetto and several concentration camps
including majdanek treblinka and
auschwitz irene was a slave laborer
in germany and was liberated by the
american in counties
by the time the war broke out irene
already was an accomplished singer and
songwriter
in her testimony she recalls singing
existing songs
and composing new ones together with her
young fellow prisoners
from poland and the soviet union the
poem sachisaki otherwise known as anima
amin
i believe was written by the poet
translator physician and writer chaul
chavnichowski
in odessa ukraine then russian empire in
1892
czernikovsky was born in ukraine to a
modern religious family
studied languages in odessa where he
became involved in zionist activities
czernikovsky served as a doctor in
russian army during world war one
and then pursuing his dream he
repatriated
or immigrated to the land of israel to
defend palestine in 1931.
i believe is one of chernikovsky's very
early poems
permeated by idealistic feelings the
young poet
unites the ideals of liberty fraternity
peace and zionist ideals the jewish
people's hope and aspiration to
freely live in their ancestral land the
land of israel
it is really moving and symbolic how all
these ideals strongly resonated with the
feelings
of the young inmates at the ghettos and
camps
among which was irene the songs like
this help
them survive and make it to the
liberation day
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
mommy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
in her testimony irene recalls that
while being transported from the
bialystol ghetto
to an unknown destination she
and other young people in the catholic
began singing
they sang as she says patriotic songs
sion his songs we were singing ourselves
to go to die she says one of these songs
whose melody she wrote herself was in
russian
because she says the boy who wrote the
words
didn't know any yiddish they did not
sing
for long because the guards on the train
shouted to them to stop and fired into
the cattle car
wounding irene and killing one of the
lads
the transport passed by the
extermination camp treblinka
and she remembers seeing vast fields
covered with ashes and bones
but they went on to lublin and she
subsequently
was taken to the nearby concentration
and extermination camp
maidanik yet irene also remembers
that the young men and women in the
cattle car sang another song
and she beautifully sings a few verses
of it
the song is known as saki saki
although its original name is i believe
anima amin
irene does not mention the name of the
song
and erroneously attributes it to haim
nachman bialik
in fact it is based on a poem written by
shaolin
another important jewish zionist poet
from ukraine
who like bialik ended up living in
palestine
czernikovsky was born in a small
ukrainian village
in 1875 and wrote sakisaki
in 1894 when he was merely 19 years old
at the time he was living in odessa and
already knew
both russian and hebrew he subsequently
also learned german english and french
as well
as ancient greek and latin a man of
great talent and energy
he studied medicine at the universities
of heidelberg
lausanne and kiev while studying at
heidelberg
czernikovsky also married the anarchist
russian
aristocrat melania karlovna
a christian of polish german and
ukrainian descent
the marriage lasted until his death in
1943.
czanikovsky served as a military doctor
in the russian army
in world war one and immigrated with his
wife and daughter to palestine
in 1931. he spent the last
years of his life having contracted
leukemia
in the greek patriarchs residence in san
simon
in jerusalem along with his wife who had
become
a devout orthodox christian
czernikovsky is remembered as one of the
most influential
poets of his generation and his works
betray
the influence of his jewish heritage his
love
for biblical figures and the impact of
world literature
sakisaki which was included in
czechnichovsky's
first poetry collection published in
1898
combines a youthful belief in humanism
socialism the fraternity of nations
friendship and zionism it was very
popular
among the zionist socialist youth of
irene's generation
and it is no wonder that she and her
friends
sang it in that transport to hell
my own mother who was just a year older
than irene
also loved that poem and i still recall
her singing it
in my childhood but the song has
remained very popular
not least in israel and it is still sung
in youth movements public events and
social gatherings
and has been performed by an array of
popular singers
there are several other interesting
twists to the story
of sarisaki whose original title
anima amin refers to a pronouncement
in the jewish prayer book siddu based
on the writings of maimonides which
expresses the 13
main principles of jewish faith
the words of anima amin were made into a
popular hasidic tune
the well-known cantor as real fasttag
is said to have sung this hasidic tune
on the train to treblinka where he was
murdered
but unlike this hasidic tune the melody
of sarkisaki sounds distinctly russian
officially the composer of this song is
said to have been
tuvya shlonsky a zionist
from a hasidic family in ukraine and the
father
of the influential hebrew poet editor
and translator
avaham shlonsky one of my own father's
early mentors when he began his own
literary career
it is however quite likely that the tune
of sarkisaki
originated in a russian folk song from
the dawn region
one indication of that is that the very
same melody
was used for another song written by
rabbi avraham
eliao kaplan a major orthodox figure
from lithuania
which he wrote as a 17 year old lad
the song which expresses the spiritual
torment
of a young soul and its longing for god
is officially titled prayer tifila
but it is known and sung to this day
under the name
the sun has set ahama
says it is unlikely that rabbi kaplan
also wrote the tune
we can assume that it was put to music
using the same popular russian tune that
was used
for sakisaki a russian song that served
to animate both a hasidic longing for
god
and a zionist socialist longing for
equality
fraternity and a new jewish generation
in earth israel one can find the
beautiful performance
of the sun has set by the hasidic singer
abhishebrot on youtube
the popularity of sakisaki in israel
to this day found another remarkable
expression
in 2004 during a discussion
in the israeli knesset on the collective
rights of
of the arab population in israel
at one point in the lengthy debate the
arab member
of knesset muhammad baraka proposed
that chernihovsky sakisaki would be a
more appropriate national anthem
than the current one which speaks
primarily
about the longing of jews to zion the
proposal was rejected
but it is a tantalizing idea
perhaps one day charnikhovsky's verse
for my soul still longs for freedom
i have not sold it to the golden calf
for i have still faith in humanity
and in its spirit fierce and bold
sung by jewish youth on the way to
treblinka
will still become the national anthem of
both
jews and palestinians in the state
of israel
[Music]
you